- Everybody, we are back,
and in the second season of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
we introduced something new,
something to get us out of the studio
and face to face with guests safely.
I'd hop in the car and head to the movies
for what we call our drive interviews.
♪ Drive-Interview ♪
- My favorite one.
♪ Ooh ♪
That's my favorite one.
I got to catch up with so many people.
Jay Leno, Cedric the
Entertainer, Neve Campbell,
Dr. Phil, just to name a few.
Check out some of the moments
we've never shared with y'all before.
(upbeat music)
- What's up?
- Hey.
Fancy meeting you here.
- How are you?
I am so excited that
you're here at the drive-in
and I am too cause I'm a huge fan.
- Aww.
- You look very at home in this truck.
- You look very at home.
What kind of wheels are those?
What do you got?
- This is a '57 Chevy.
- This is a 1970 Dodge Challenger.
- I hear you have an eight year old son
that's actually teaching you about cars,
and I don't know if you
need to be taught though,
cause this is a pretty
cool car you're riding.
What was the first car you ever drove?
Cause that's a pretty fly car.
- The first car I ever drove
was a '77 Coupe DeVille.
It was my mom's car.
And I did the thing where I got a wreck,
where I'd, you know...
Well, it wasn't a bad one.
I just scraped it on the passenger side
and she never saw it
because she would drive.
- And you didn't tell her?
- What?
No.
So then when she finally
discovered it, I was like, really?
I wonder when that happened.
- Who did that?
- That's terrible.
- Do you think driving,
I mean, I don't know,
do you think it is therapeutic?
I feel it's therapeutic.
- It can be, if you're
not in this LA traffic,
which hasn't been bad.
That's one good thing
of the pandemic, right?
The traffic hasn't been so bad.
- Yeah.
- But it can be.
I mean, particularly if
you kind of kick back,
put on some tunes, put your
cruise control on and roll.
It really can be kind of therapeutic.
- I like to get out and, you know, drive,
especially like during the pandemic,
that's what I've been doing.
Like just kind of riding
around, hanging out.
- I feel like I'm in high school again.
That's what I used to do
when I first got a car.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- I was like, I'm gonna drive around.
Do you sing in the car?
Cause I am the tool that
you will pull up next to
and I am jamming.
- Yeah, well Kelly, you can jam.
- I look like an idiot though.
It's not like cool jam.
- I sound like a pig under a gate.
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
- I gotta totally be by myself
though with the windows up.
- You won't let people hear.
- Oh hell no.
- You're my favorite people
at karaoke bars, by the way.
The ones that aren't good.
- Yeah, no I'm your favorite
people at karaoke bars,
just sit in the back and
watch people that sing.
- Well, until we get just enough alcohol,
like a little liquid courage in you,
and then you're like all
right, I can do this.
- Yeah, you ain't got a big
enough jug to get me up there.
- You should try moonshine.
Do you have a favorite movie
that you've ever seen at a drive-in?
- Yeah.
I can just go back to
like the first "Shaft",
like being a kid, like seeing
that at a drive-in movie,
and then Bruce Lee movies.
Those were the ones that
we used to go and see,
like the cool Kung Fu
movies when they came out.
"Fist of Fury".
- The fury, yeah.
- "Fist of Fury".
- My first one was actually a Batman,
the first Batman.
- Oh really?
With the best Batman, Michael Keaton.
- Michael Keaton as Batman, of course.
That's the best Batman.
- Yeah I love 'em all,
but no, Michael Keaton,
he wins it for me.
- Yeah of course, he's so cool.
- It's cool, but I cam for
the snacks, I'm gonna be real.
I like the snacks.
- I have snacks.
I've got some Good & Plentys,
I got some Junior Mints.
- Junior Mints, that's my mom's favorite.
- That's my kids' favorite.
- I love Milk Duds, but whatever,
but they stick in your teeth.
I don't like that part.
- Wait, I have a question though,
because I have a theory about
Red Viness versus Twizzlers.
- Twizzlers all the way.
- Okay, so everyone from the east coast,
but you're not east
coast, likes Twizzlers,
and everyone out here in
California likes Red Vines,
and I can't eat Red Vines.
- Since I've been in California,
it's all about the Red Vine game.
- Okay, that's a little bit
of an imitation game for me.
- My wife is a Red Viner, so you know,
that made me a Red Viner at that point.
- Okay, I like it.
- Once your wife becomes something...
That's it, that's it.
- Bit of compromise.
- Twizzlers are way better.
- And I chew off the ends
and I get a Coke and then...
Yep, yep.
That's what I do.
What have you found yourself
doing like during quarantine,
like since we've seen each other?
- Well, you see, I look
at the positive side
of this corona thing.
- Can you tell me what that is?
- Well, that is, as a guy, go, honey,
I'd love to take you to
that new vegan restaurant,
but it's closed, we can't...
Honey, I'd love to see "Hamilton",
but the theaters, they're
not doing it right now.
Honey, I want, I'd love
to take you to Europe,
but they won't let us in.
So for a lot of guys, this
is actually pretty good.
- It's like seems like
we've just gotta stay here.
- Yeah.
Honey, I'll go to In N
Out, I'll get some burgers,
and bring 'em back and
we'll have a dinner here.
- That is an upside, I guess.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's amazing.
You're an optimist.
- I'm an optimist.
That's right.
- You are.
- Well, hey, we've gotta do this again.
- We do.
I love meeting up like this.
You know what it's like?
It's like an old detective
movie where we got like,
I got some stuff, maybe
I dumped some stuff
off in the trunk and then you say hey-
- Maybe I've got a body
in the truck, who knows?
- You have.
You've got the perfect trunk for a body.
- Did you grow up doing drive-ins?
- Oh yeah.
- I think my mother has told me the story
that my father made my mother
get in the trunk of a car
so he didn't have to pay
or something to get her in.
- Oh yeah, that was a thing.
- [Kelly] That's truly a muscle car.
- [Wilmer] His name is Spawn.
- His name is Spawn, and
where did that come from?
- So, one of my favorite
action comic books
is by the name of "Spawn", is basically,
it's this comic book character that
became really big and
underground in the nineties.
And then eventually I started
naming things after him.
- His name is Sunny.
I saw him literally driving by in Texas,
like far away in a dealership.
And I was like, he will be mine.
- [Wilmer] Was it yellow?
- Yeah.
I love him.
- That's amazing.
- [Wilmer] That's incredible.
- He looked like he was like straight up
out of like "Fried Green
Tomatoes", the movie,
and I was like, you're cute.
It's wood paneling
floorboard, it's adorable.
- Oh, man.
That's so good.
- Everything is still old school on it.
- It's all original?
- Mm-hmm, yeah, I love it.
- [Wilmer] That's a tough
one to keep, you know,
tuned up if you're not driving it.
You've gotta spin that one a little.
- Yeah, like I can change
oil and change a tire,
and that's really what I can do.
- First of all, your change oil?
I haven't changed oil
in probably 20 years.
- Oh I haven't changed oil in a while,
but I can change oil.
- I'm still impressed.
- I think Texas women, I think
they make you in the south,
at least learn how to do it
if you're on the side of the road.
- See you for you and the south,
they teach you how to change oil.
For us, they teach us how to
salsa dance at three years old.
- We line dance.
I would have preferred...
I like line dancing
but salsa would've been
a lot more sexier.
But, anyway.
Are you the kind of guy that
has family like all around you?
Do they live near you?
- Yeah, yeah.
You know, a little while ago
I bought the neighbor's house
and I moved my mom there.
The timing couldn't have been better
because then pandemic hits.
- Does that feel so good to be able to
give that back to your mom like that?
Like she gave so much
of herself for you to...
- No, it's amazing.
It's unbelievable.
And honestly, when we
came to the United States,
we were all we had.
We had to start from scratch.
My mom was a big factor
of why we turned out
any kind of reasonable, you know,
and she also gave something back to me
when I ate Colombian
food the entire pandemic.
- Nostalgia in isolating time.
- Oh, for sure.
For sure.
But I think that like, you
know, the food was incredible,
and to just to sit with
my mom and not having...
You know how it is, we're traveling,
if we're not on set, we're doing...
You know, we're showing
up for social causes.
- It's the first time we had to slow down.
- Yeah, first time to
really look at each other
and really talk to one another,
besides like the short talk, right?
Like, how are you?
Good, all right, great,
who did that, who did this?
But this was the first
time where like, you know,
my fiance got to ask
questions like, you know,
what were you like, like a kid, you know?
And I found out so many
things about my mom
that I was just like, I don't know why
I never asked you that.
You know.
And just when you think
you know your parents,
you really don't.
And we don't ever ask our
parents or grandparents questions
about their childhood
or how they were like,
or whatever, we take it for what it is.
- And you start to see your parent
as like a 20 something
year old in their stories
and you're like, man,
I would have probably
been friends with you.
Like that's so cool.
- Like my mom was telling
me about ex-boyfriends
and so I was like, what,
you had ex-boyfriends?
- Yeah, we hate him.
- Oh we hate him.
Yeah, so that was definitely
a big moment for me too,
to kind of get to know her even more.
- You're so great.
- You are so great.
Are you kidding?
- I mean you're already
like a really cool guy
in the limelight, I just mean like, wow,
you're like such a family guy.
That's so cool.
- [Wilmer] Oh, thank you.
- Not everybody is like
open and vulnerable
and like, you know, some
people can be guarded.
- I think all of us male actors, you know,
we're lead to believe that we have to say,
sound, look a certain way.
I'm too Latin for that, man.
You know, I'm from Colombia
and Venezuela, like,
what you see is what you get with me.
- Well, before we go, can I
hear like a rev from Spawn?
- Sure, sure.
(engine revs)
- Woo!
I love your car!
All right, I'll see you next time!
- See you next time!